years I had the honor to sit on its
board so I could witness
firsthand the role of the Eda um as the
pivot of European Defense
Corporation but I must also say in the
last four years I learned something
about the Eda and that is how you work
not only with National Defense ministers
but with all European
institutions and we've seen it since
Russian tanks rolled into
Ukraine all of Europe has sustained
Ukraine's war effort and of course this
has required a great deal of
collaboration between different
institutions including the agency and
the
commission our Joint Defense joint
procurement task force for example is
helping us to match the demand of our
Our member states with the production
capacities of our
industry and together we have powered up
Ukraine's
resistance we have demonstrated what we
can achieve as a union when we join
forces across borders and institutions
and together with Partners at
NATO and this
closer defense cooperation will be more
and more
necessary we all know that the Strategic
environment around us has fundamentally
changed and this creates a new kind of
responsibility for Europe I call it
strategic
responsibility it is a
responsibility first of all to support
Ukraine in this war for as long as it
takes and this will not be easy
but it is
exactly when our commitment needs to be
Rock
Solid Russia is now reinforcing its
positions trying to retake the
initiative and this
means that the situation on the
battlefield remains very
challenging but this is not an argument
against support on the contrary
it is an argument for more
support because let's not forget when
Putin invaded Ukraine many of us thought
it will only take days to take Kei this
has not
happened currently Putin does not even
control all the territories he has
already
annexed
Ukraine has driven Russia out of half
the territories captured after February
Ukraine has even pushed the Russian
Fleet in the Black Sea back and is able
to deliver grain again through this
Maritime
Corridor Finland has become a NATO
member with a long border with
Russia Sweden soon will
be Ukraine is on its way to EU
membership and the
Kremlin has deprived itself of access to
Western economy iies and Innovation
systems and made itself dependent on
China we have achieved a lot together
and all these are good Arguments for
sustained support to
Ukraine at the same time we must must
also look at Ukraine's Security in the
medium and long
term Ukraine must have the capabilities
to deter further attacks by
Russia and this is why the eu's future
security commitments to Ukraine are so
vital but strategic responsibility is
not only about
Ukraine it is also about the other
future members of our Union like the
Western
Balkan where long standing local
grievances are now being manipulated by
external
and if we look only a bit further
conflicts have multiplied all around our
borders I think of course of the Middle
East but also of the Sahel and the
caucuses
globally strategic competition is
intensifying our partners are asking for
greater European engagement in other
parts of the world such as the Indo
Pacific and we must recognize that our
security is more closely interlined than
ever
before we have learned that when a big
country threatens a small
neighbor the whole rules-based order is
at
stake and of course our trade routs and
Supply chains are also
exposed Europe might be called to play a
role in any of these theaters near or
far so we need member States armed
forces that are prepared for all sorts
of scenarios from traditional to hybrid
on land at Sea in the air in outer space
or cyers
space we always say that our Union was
born at as a peace project and yes this
is
right but peace requires
security and that's why our Union was
also born as a security
project its industrial Genesis with coal
and steel had a Central Security
dimension in those
sectors the common industrial policy was
basically sec security
policy and then through the decades this
security Dimension has
grown I'm not only referring to the
birth of this agency or to our missions
and
operations most of our Union's
policies have Direct Security
implications our transpar
policy for military
Mobility our agricultural policy
for food
security from trade to research from
energy to
Communications at times of unprecedented
threats we must refocus our attention on
the security dimension of all our
policies we must once again think about
our Union as
intrinsically a security
project of of course and this is very
important Collective defense remains
primarily the responsibility of the
member states and of
NATO and we fully respect this specific
point our cooporation with NATO remains
Central it's excellent and it is
stronger than
ever but strategic
responsibility also calls for stronger
European contribution within NATO and to
Nato and since the beginning of Russia's
fullscale war of
aggression the idea of strategic
responsibility has driven our work on
defense so I want to focus today on how
the work we have done so far can shape
our future progress on European
defense ladies and
gentlemen the European Defense Agency is
about to turn
20 we've built our defense cooporation
step by step Brick by
Brick and when Russia invaded Ukraine in
2022 Decades of patient excellent work
allowed us to react quickly and
decisively
we have resorted every tool in our hands
in unprecedented
ways just let me explain a few of those
we had
created the European peace facility to
strengthen our role as security provider
on other
continents now for the first time
ever we are giving military aid to a
country of in at War right here in
Europe
5.6 billion euros coordinated at EU
level to deliver tanks helicopters air
defense systems missiles and am
ammunition to
Ukraine we had organized training
missions
before now for the first time ever we're
training troops involved in an
interstate European war with a
mission commanded by the new Brussels
headqu
Waters we had created the European
Defense Fund in Pesco I remember that
very well from my time as defense
minister to promote Cooperative defense
spending now for the first time ever
we're mobilizing Europe's defense
industry to sustain a war
effort the European Defense fund has
been complemented by edira
and it has led to ASAP you know it well
the act in support of ammunition
production 480,000 rounds of artillery
shells have been either delivered or are
in the
pipeline and already next year we will
be able to produce 1 million rounds per
year this would have been
unimaginable just two years
ago and it already marks a massive step
forward for our defense
cooperation what we have done would be
extraordinary in normal
times but in these extraordinary times
it is not
enough the war in Ukraine demonstrates
that we need to produce more both to
meet Ukraine's need and to ensure our
own deterrence and
defense the war in Ukraine is consuming
more Hardware than any other war in
recent
history Russia has fired 10 million
shells in a
year Ukraine consumes 10,000 drones per
month this means that Europe's defense
industry must mobilize
too the reality is
that we did not have sufficient weapons
and ammunitions
available no large
stocks and the lack of spare
capacity because in peace time we
thought we did not need
them this needed to
change so in July NATO leaders endorsed
a new NATO defense production action
plan and here in the European union we
need need to be laser focused on our own
production
capabilities no industrial batttle deck
should prevent us from securing
Europe there is no lack of European
instruments at our
disposal there are projects of great
interest from long range drones to a
system to detect and neutralize sea
mines that could prove V vital for
instance in the Black
Sea but
overall our instruments for cooperation
are still punching below their
weight now the good news is that there's
much greater scope for the necessary
Investments after the recent surge in
many National Defense
budget the 2% NATO goal is within reach
for more and more member states and this
is good because because strategic
responsibility requires adequate defense
spending but how is the money
spent collaborative spending by member
states has only slightly improved it is
still below
20% very far from our goal of
35% and on top of this the latest
figures
show that additional funds are in large
majority spent outside the European
Union so we are predominantly buying
alone and buying
abroad and of course this is happening
because of the urgency to get weapons to
Ukraine and restock National
inventories but this wave of short-term
Acquisitions will have a long-term
impact
first of all it has an economic
cost when member states Buy in an
uncoordinated way this may drive up
prices secondly it has a competitiveness
cost for our
industry these Investments could Foster
Innovation and economies of scale in
Europe instead of buying off-the-shelf
products
elsewhere
thirdly it has a military
cost there are way too many different
weapon systems in
Europe and this leads to a lack of
interoperability there are many examples
but let me give you one the Dutch German
Brigade usth the same type of
Howitzer but the Dutch have a certain
type of Amun ammunition for the Howitzer
the Germans have a certain type of
ammunition for the howitzer
and they are not
interoperable so both cannot each the
one or the others this is just one
example but you all know here in the
room many other examples and we could
give you many other more this cannot
continue finally buying a loan and
buying abroad may also have a security
cost we should not
assume that we will always be able to
rely on the international market for our
defense
procurement we must look into our
strategic
dependencies to avoid operational
consequences on the
battlefield and just like we need
military Readiness in a fast changing
security environment we also need
industrial
Readiness this is an essential component
of strategic
responsibility we must move from a logic
of emergency
response to one of longterm
security we need to make up for decades
of underinvestment and
fragmentation and to overcome this we
need to spend more spend
better and spend
together
ladies and
gentlemen transatlantic Corporation will
remain essential including from an
industrial point of
you but we also need a stronger European
reflex we must think European from
planning to
procurement and there are lessons here
that we can learn from our recent
history beyond the defense and security
field in the four years of this
mandate Europe's way of doing industrial
policy has been
transformed for instance on
hydrogen on semiconductors chips or on
critical raw
materials there was first a political
decision taken at European
level our union agreed to focus on
certain critical
industries that are Cent Cal for our
economy of
tomorrow
then we improved our rules to facilitate
investment and
Innovation for instance with faster
permitting and emergency emergency Frame
Works and
finally we backed our new industrial
priorities with
European and National Funds to address
market failures
and this is the approach that we would
also like to replicate with the new
European Defense industrial
strategy this European Defense
industrial strategy will focus on four
strands of work and let me display them
first strategic
planning of course we can build on the
Strategic compass and on the work the ER
AA is doing with member states to
coordinate National Defense
planning but to deliver on our strategic
priorities we need even more joint
programming we should identify Flagship
capabilities at European
level projects of common
interest on which we must focus our
efforts and resources
for instance capabilities that are
European by Nature like the Strategic
enablers like cyber capabilities or
satellites or strategic
Transportation but I also think of
complex
platforms that are beyond the capacity
of individual member states like air
defense and that can benefit from
European
scale so we need a strategic iic
planning function that ties together
National and EU level
planning and this will give
predictability to the
industry and reduce
fragmentation on the demand and supply
side second we need simpler and more
efficient
rules just like we did in other fields
we can use our regulatory framework to
Foster and to simplify
cooperation this is an even more necess
this is even more necessary in a heavily
regulated sector like
defense so in the consultation phase of
our
strategy we will ask our
industry how we can best support
it we need an updated regulatory
framework
to give the industry and member states
predictability and coherence on a
continental
scale my third point is maximize our
dual use
potential while we strengthen our
defense specific research and
development we should also better
integrate civilian
Technologies in our defense industrial
base
we have already done this for instance
on Military
Mobility dual use transport
infrastructure you're well familiar with
that like roads and bridges that are
used by military convoys are essential
for our security and
deter so we have worked with the
transport
community and accelerated the use of our
funds and policies in that field so
there's a good example for that it is
still work in progress but it is already
one of the success stories of European
Defense and this dual use
model is also applied in other sectors
for instance on satellites for global
positioning and secure
connectivity we have already
Galileo we will soon have
Iris which are EU
assets and serve a military
function and we are laying the ground
for European cyber
Shield so the European Union could have
a direct role in creating new dual use
infrastructure such as vital Innovation
with defense application that emerges
from civilian
activities important is now that we
connect the
dots and for this the commission will
set out options in a white paper on Dual
use
research my fourth point is about
mobilizing public and private
funding a suite of funding instruments
is already
available but we must explore all
possible ways to reward to
incentivize and to compensate cost of
Corporation and indust industrial
competitiveness the strategy will do so
including by suggesting new funding
possibilities we will propose a European
Defense Industry Program earlier next
year this will integrate the experience
of ASAP and
edpa and of course without prejudging
the negotiations on the future EU budget
buet it needs to be adequately
funded we're also looking at how to
incentivize the
transition from Cooperative research
under the EDF to the development and
fullscale industrial
production of Defense
systems ASAP was a good first step but
of course it was limited to an already
mature product and this is
ammunition so we should look at the
whole cycle of capability
development Bill including the stage of
industrial implementation and industrial
production all with a view to guide and
support our defense technological and
Industrial base in light of our
strategic
priorities and this would allow for
greater coherence and
coordination
but there are other options too we are
already working on the vat exemption to
support the joint procurement and joint
ownership of Defense
capabilities we have already called on
the European Investment Bank to enhance
its support to European Defense
industry and this call was recently
echoed by member states and the Ada
steering board many thanks to that so I
believe it is time to finally move move
ahead
now we are looking at how the defense
industry's contribution to the security
of our Union can be better recognized by
sustainable Financial
investors and how smmes and startups in
the defense sector can get access to
growth
finance and we should finally also be
open to lessons from our partners that
let me give you an
example the lesson how the United States
create stable demand for
industry lower costs and facilitate
export trans transactions through their
foreign military sales
program we should also explore synergies
with other industrial policies for
example our critical raw materials act
that has identified some
minerals that are needed for our defense
and Space
Industries if we are to take strategic
responsibility we need these vital
values
chains and this work can only be done on
a continental
scale and finally my fifth
point we must close the
discussions on how defense
Investments
can be taken into account under our
fiscal governance rules just
discussed as a matter of
transparency spending on defense must be
counted in public depbt and deficits
like any other
category it can and should meet two
compatible
objectives ensure sustainable
finances
and support member states investment
efforts in strategic public
goods and this applies also to defense
capabilities in response to the more
threatening geopolitical
context especially because member states
have very different starting points in
this
area so already in the commission's
proposal last
April we identified
defense among the EU priorities for
investment and
reforms this could
underpin the extension of a member
State's fiscal adjustment
period in Council there is no broad
support to consider increases in defense
spending as a relevant
factor a relevant Factor when we assess
whether a member state has an excessive
deficit or
not and there is room for further
targeted and time limited
adaptation to reduce the near-term
fiscal efforts for member
states that are simultaneously
increasing their defense
spending this could be particularly
relevant for investments in the
identified critical capability
gaps in addition these Investments would
have to be Europe European collaborative
projects and this would generate a
specific incentive for crossborder
projects in Europe that are so much
needed if
acceptable co-legislators could consider
these suggestions while finalizing the
current proposals this could be a game
Cher for the Union's
defense and its defense industrial
policies in these exceptional times
so strategic
focus better
rules dual
use and
funding these are the four main pillars
of our upcoming
strategy but at the end there
are some topics more that I want to
raise about the geographic scope of our
work a strategic approach to our defense
industry must also look into the
question of Ukraine's defense
capabilities on top of our own
needs our strategy can only be complete
if it also takes into account Ukraine's
needs and Ukraine's industrial
capacity the first step to achieve this
is to involve
Ukraine in the consultation process of
the industrial
strategy this should lead to integrating
Ukraine in some of our defense
programs with the agreement of the
European Parliament and the council
where
necessary this will not only help us
cater for Ukraine's defense
needs it will of course also encourage
convergence and Joint planning between
between our militaries and defense
Industries Ukraine is a future member of
our European Union so it m must get much
closer to us and much faster and we
should use all our tools to make this
happen ladies and gentlemen these last
years have
shown that when there is a political
will there is a
way when we come together things that
were stuck for
years can start moving
again in these eventful times we must be
driven by a strong sense of
urgency and we must expand our
cooperation as much as possible in the
current institutional
boundaries but we shouldn't shy away
from asking bold
questions about the future of European
Defense we will not be able to answer
all these questions in the short term in
the few months ahead of the European
elections but we should still strive to
set out a vision for the next
steps and imagine how the industrial and
security policy
tools that support our strategic
responsibility can help to complete our
European Defense
Union to me the most urgent would
be to look into new
possibilities for our defense
cooperation under the current
treaties there are strong arguments to
align the procurement conditions of the
EPF and
edpa both can serve the immediate
procurement needs of member states and
Ukraine
Ukraine as well as reinforcing the
European and Ukrainian defense
industrial
base both functions are vital to the
long-term security of the member states
and of
Ukraine and while respecting the
constraints of the
treaties I see scope to discuss whether
at
least that function of the EPF could be
supported by the union budget in a
future
multiannual Financial
framework these are
questions that we should ask already
today and this is why we will already
make
proposals in our contribution to the
leaders discussions on the future of
Europe that will be held under the
Belgium presidency now this next six
month of or the first half of
2024 ladies and and gentlemen our
Union's
founders
believed that defense and
security had to be Central in the
European
project today this is more true than
ever
before we have made tangible
progress towards a European Defense
Union but the Strategic challenges we
Face have grown even
faster
now look at how much our Union has
changed in recent
years when the pandemic
hit we all realized that we need more
integration to address Health
emergencies and since then we have laid
the foundation of a European health
union when Russia tried to Blackmail us
with gas we all realized that we needed
common investment common action and even
common aggregate purchase of
gas and since then the European energy
Union has advanced more than ever
before the next
chapter is a full-fledged European
Defense
Union so that Europe can finally take
strategic
responsibility for its own
future it is one of the big tasks that
our Union faces for the years
ahead and I'm confident that Europe will
once again answer the call of
History thank you very much and Long
Live
Europe hey
Joseph to see you how are you no good to
see you f bruss report and I had to go
to Le oh so